quand kepler observé l'obscurité du ciel
la nuit il les voyait la finitude de
l'univers en effet si l'univers était
infini s'il y avait des étoiles un peu
partout dans cet univers alors quelle
que soit la direction dans laquelle on
regarde notre regard devrait croiser
l'une des étoiles de l'univers
cependant les cosmologistes modernes y
voir autre chose pour les cosmologistes
moderne l'obscurité du ciel révèle en
fait la finitude de sondage avant de
commencer il faut que l'on parle de
formule 1 vous l'entendez c'est l'effet
doppler considérons une source avec un
signal très régulier si je ne bouge pas
par rapport à la source
je l'entends à la bonne fréquence 1 tick
par seconde
quand la source se rapproche de moi
l'éthique que j'entends sont plus
fréquents vous l'entendez pour
comprendre pourquoi
notez que les tic en différentes
origines spatiale et vous voyez que les
front d'onde sont alors rapprochés
al'inverse camps-la-source s'éloigne de
doux les tic sont moins fréquents en
termes de son les signaux de fréquences
plus grande correspondent à du son plus
grave et ça ça veut dire que le son de
sources qui s'éloigne de nous
apparaissent gras que si l'on ne
bougeait pas par rapport aux sources
c'est ce que l'on appelle l'effet
doppler et plus la source d'un son va
vite plus l'effet doppler et grands ça
explique le son est formé et que
j'entendais en fait très qu'on est
content l effet de doper à on peut
savoir que la formule 1 va très vite et
d'ailleurs c'est en mesurant les fais
dodo peur de ma voiture que j'ai reçu
cette amende
ce phénomène qui s'applique aux sons
s'appliquait la lumière aussi même si
l'explication physique est un peu
différente
au lieu de rendre le sont plus graves
l'effet doppler fait paraître la lumière
des sources qui s'éloigne de nous plus
rouge c'est ce que l'on appelle le
décalage vers le rouge dans les années
1930 le maître rebelles ont observé ce
décalage vers le rouge pour les galaxies
lointaines
qui plus est ils remarquèrent que plus
les galaxy était lointaine plus grand
était le décalage vers le rouge
les galaxies lointaines subissent un
plus grand effet doppler lemaître et
robben conclure alors que les galaxies
lointaines s'éloigner plus vite que les
galaxies proches
c'est ce que l'on appelle la loi de
hubble en fait la loi nome baldy un peu
plus que cela a dit que la vitesse à
laquelle une galaxies s'éloignent de
nous est proportionnelle à sa distance
par rapport à nous de façon cruciale
remontant le temps ceci implique que
toute la matière originelle d'un point
unique en fait
en combinant la thermodynamique est
mécanique quantique et la relativité
générale le maître en vain a affirmé que
notre univers tout entier était il ya
très longtemps un unique point tonnes
d'énergie
un atome primitif un pic bang et bien
sûr tout le monde était d'accord avec le
m en fait non plus par des contemporains
de lemaître y compris abn arguait que
juste parce que l'univers était en
expansion n'impliquait pas qu'ils
avaient une origine
ouais j'imagine que beaucoup de
physiciens à l'époque à la nascar
d'einstein adoré l'idée d'un univers
statique et éternelle mais il ya aussi
une raison plus rationnel alors
confusion
les calculs de robes elle suggérait que
l'expansion de l'univers avait commencé
il y à deux milliards d'années ce qui
est super étrange sachant que les
analyses des particules radioactives
indiqué que la terre était âgé d'au
moins 4,5 milliards d'années
comment l'univers peut-il être plus
jeunes que les choses qu'il contient est
ce qu'il ya une sorte d' accélération du
temps ici sur terre
non ce qui est assez calcul de rebelles
étaient faux mais personne ne le savait
c'est pourquoi en 1948 quand le
physicien fred hoyle prouva que en
supposant une création spontanée
continue mais extrêmement rare de
matières l'univers pouvait être à la
fois statique est en expansion éternelle
beaucoup de personnes furent convaincus
après tout ils avaient là entre ses
mains une théorie de l'espace temps
qu'ils étaient en accord à la voix avec
halo doble l'âge de la terre et toutes
les observations faites à l'époque
du coup tout le monde crut en vol et
tout le monde oublie ya le m cependant
de nouveaux arguments en faveur du big
bang virent le jour dans un tout autre
domaine de la physique à la fin des
années 40 les experts de la physique
nucléaire était complètement déconcertée
par l'abondance des éléments légers
comme l'hydrogène et l'hélium
malgré l'absence de mécanismes naturels
pour les produire alpher et d'autres
remarquèrent alors que cette abondance
pouvait être très bien expliqué si
l'univers avait connu une phase très
dense et fabuleusement énergétique
ce serait pendant cette phase que les
atomes les jets auraient été produits en
très grande quantité
durant cette phase l'univers aurait
alors été une soupe primordiale chaudes
et lumineuses des frais drôle rétorquait
que si cette phase avait existé elle
serait encore visibles dans le ciel
les observateurs avaient beau regarder
le ciel aussi longtemps qu'il le voulait
le ciel la nuit était et est encore noir
du coup les idées de leur fait oublier
des décennies plus tard en 1965 dit que
et peebles redécouvrir les idées d'al
feurs mais entre-temps les technologies
avait amélioré les performances de
vision nocturne
si bien que dit que et peebles espérer
qu'il pourrait détecter la soupe aux
primordial que leur théorie du big bang
prédisait il savait que s'il détectait
cette soupe primordiale
il ferait ainsi l'une des plus grandes
découvertes de l'histoire des sciences
reçurent alors un coup de fil dit que
écoute en se retournant vers pi2 et
s'exclame ah on s'est fait devancé par
accident les observateurs penzias et
wilson avait détecté ce qu'il pensait
être un boy dérangeant qui venaient de
toutes les directions
après avoir suspecté délit de pigeon
dans leur antenne penzias wilson se
rendirent compte que ce bruit
correspondait exactement à la soupe
primordiale call for avait prédit des
décennies plus tôt notre ciel et
lumineux incroyablement lumineux mais
l'expansion astronomique de notre
univers avait créé un effet de doper
leurs massifs qui avaient décalé vers le
rouge à lumière de la soupe primordiale
et l'avait rendu infrarouge si
infrarouge que dose ie ne sont pas
capables de la voir aujourd'hui cette
lumière très brillante
présente partout dans le ciel mais très
décalée vers le rouge et ce qu'on
appelle le fond diffus cosmologique ou
rayonnement fossile et c'est
l'observation qui a fait triompher la
théorie du big bang quand on y pense
c'est quand même incroyablement cool
quand on regarde le ciel la nuit nos
yeux capture des photons qui ont
traversé l'univers tout entier juste
pour nous donner un aperçu des premiers
instants de notre espace-temps
la dernière fois on a parlé de la fin
des temps et de la constante
cosmologique et je vous avais dit qu'à
cause de la constante cosmologique
certains endroits dans l'univers
s'éloigner de nous une vitesse
supérieure à la vitesse de la lumière et
j -luc a réagi à ça en disant que dans
des vidéos précédentes j'ai dit moi même
que la vitesse de la lumière était la
vitesse maximale à travers des espaces
temps et bien super commentaires de
l'art qui explique comment résoudre ce
paradoxe
j'ai un petit peu insister sur un
certain point le fait que en fait
techniquement en relativité générale les
seuls vitesse dont on devrait avoir le
droit de parler sont des vitesses
relative un endroit précis de l'espace
temps outremont dit ou ne peut
techniquement comparer la vitesse de
deux trajectoires à travers l'espace
temps uniquement leur point
d'intersection dans l'espace dont et à
ce moment là la vitesse entre les deux
objets à cet endroit précis de l'espace
temps va être en un certain sens une
sorte d' angles entre ces deux
trajectoires travers l'espace temps donc
si je dis qu'une formule 1 va 300
kilomètres à vide comparé à moi ce que
je suis en train de vraiment dire c'est
que mon moment de notre intersections à
travers l'espace temps la trajectoire de
la formule faisait espèces dans l'ue
avec ma trajectoire qui correspondait à
cette vitesse de 300 km quand on dit que
la vitesse de la lumière et la vitesse
maximale ce que l'on veut dire c'est que
l'ongle au maximum entre deux
trajectoires à travers l'espace temps et
tu en angle qui correspond à la vitesse
de la lumière et du coup si on prend
deux points qui sont très éloignées à
travers l'espace temps a priori on n'a
pas vraiment le droit de parler de leur
vie des chevaliers parce qu'on ne peut
pas vraiment mesuré l'ongle il faudrait
transporté parallèlement un point envers
l'autre mais techniquement en toute
généralité
si je vous laisse il mesure 1 espèce
d'angle entre deux trajectoires à
travers l'espace temps il faudrait que
je transporte parallèlement le nez
trajectoire vers l'autre or sous le
résultat que j'obtiendrais dépendra du
chemin que j'utilise pour faire ce
transport parallèle dans tout ça c'est
un petit peu compliqué pc pour vous
expliquer qu'un moment donc la protéger
la qualité générale j'étais complètement
perdu et que je pensais qu'il veut juste
pas le droit de comparer la vitesse
relative entre deux points très éloigné
dans l'espace temps en fait ce qui va
nous sauver ici pour voir quand même
parler de vitesse relative c'est le fait
que vont se place
un métriques de freedom house dans
laquelle on a supposé que l'espace était
homogène et on présente un espace
homogène on peut considérer que chaque
tranche de l'espace est une tranche de
simultanéité et en particulier fois
qu'on a fait ça non seulement d'un
espace commun pour tous les observateurs
du vermont aussi un tank au moins qui
veut être l'orthogonalité se passe du
coup on peut parler à ce moment-là de
vitesse relative entre deux objets très
éloigné dans l'espace-temps ton
calculant la variation de la distance
entre ces deux objets dans l'espace reçu
pause et homogène à travers un temps qui
à ce moment là se trouve être le même
pour tous les observateurs de
l'espace-temps bon malgré ce charabia ça
peut quand même surprendre le fait que
deux objets peuvent s'éloigner une
vitesse supérieure à celle de la lumière
et là je veux reprendre le commentaire
de l'arche est un petit peu le leur
formuler à ma manière
montrer que l'on peut imaginer c'est
assez faux mais je trouve que ça aide de
l'imaginer c'est qu'en fait à chaque
instant du temps on a des boues des
espaces qui sont créés c'est l'expansion
du temps il ya plus espace du coup il ya
des bouts espaces qui sont créés à
chaque instant du temps du coup un
certain sens on a créé de l'espace entre
deux points et c'est ça qui fait que la
distance entre ces deux points à eau
bouillante et tout d'un coup et là vous
vous imaginez que l'on peut créer autant
d'aces parce que l'on veut entre deux
points et du coup avoir une vitesse
aussi grande que l'on veut entre ces
deux points ceci nous mène aux
commentaires de pixels 29 34 qui se
demandent si l'espace se contracte à
travers le temps donc ça c'est à peu
près le cas près d'une mosquée centrale
est ce que l'on rétrécit aussi avec un
espace qui se contracte la réponse est
non à cause des forces gravitationnelles
imaginez encore une fois que ces forces
gravitationnelles dans notre quotidien
sont beaucoup plus importantes que la
courbure de l'espace-temps du coup les
effets de la coupure de l'espace-temps
sont négligeables et en particulier les
chromatismes va faire en sorte que l'on
garde toujours notre taille tout ça
parce qu'il ya des forces entre les
électrons qui sauront pouces qui est
repoussée at home les uns des autres et
du coup même si l'espace se contractent
cette forte interaction entre les écrans
qui repoussent les atomes va faire en
sorte que nos atomes ne se rapproche pas
plus et que donc on aurait très sympa
j'ai des gars en commander mais je
recommande encore il ya une vraie un
superbe vidéo de minutes physx à ce
sujet on n'a qu'à une pose la question
est ce que l'on sait temps avec
l'univers ce qu'on grandit aussi avec
l'expansion de l'univers
donc ça c'est dans le cadre du modèle du
big bang donc du coup une expansion
klaus mais tout devrait du coup grandir
ce que cette expression cosmique puisque
dix minutes physique c'est qu'à cause
des forces gravitationnelles
en fait non tout ne s'étant pas on ne
s'étant pas vraiment avec notre univers
parce que cette fois ils étaient force
attractive entre les atomes qui font que
les atomes veulent rester ensemble et ne
grossissent pas avec l'univers et ça ça
pose aussi une autre excellente question
qui apposait maïque soumaré est ce que
l'énergie noire surtout si on considère
que c'est une forme d'énergie du vide
est-ce qu'elle ne contredit pas à la
conservation de l'énergie de temps que
je vous ai dit vite fait dans l'épisode
21 puis surtout dans le défi des trois
que l'équation d'einstein de la
relativité générale d'einstein casey ou
non la construction logique au code
en haut elle fondamentalement la
conservation de l'énergie en tout point
de l'espace temps que sa création fait
que la quadri divergence du tenseur
nothing et dû transformer trick est égal
à zéro mais tout ce que ça dit c'est
qu'il y ait une concertation locale de
l'énergie tous qui aura entre depuis le
passé en un point de l'espace temps doit
au sortir donc une conservation juste au
niveau de ce point au niveau local mais
si on a créé de l'espace à travers le
temps on en quelque sorte créé des
points dans lequel il peut avoir de
l'énergie qui apparaît tout cas c'est
plus ou moins le discours de ceux qui
prend l'énergie noire comme l'expliquent
très bien matt dans cette superbe vidéo
de psp star cependant pour d'autres
physiciens comme carlo rovelli il n'y a
pas de raison de considérer qu'il existe
et sa ferrari noire
on a juste cette équation des chaînes
qui nous est donné on n'a pas besoin de
réinterpréter le lambda de mètres de
l'autre côté de l'équation pour
l'expliquer comme une sorte d'énergie
une sorte de matière à travers l'espace
temps si on le garde juste de côté
gauche notamment de l'équation considère
juste qu'il s'agit d'une composante de
l'équation fondamental de
la relativité générale et à ce moment là
on n'a pas besoin d énergie noire donc
ça sauve une hypothèse mais d'un autre
côté on a quand même une équation qui
est pas super you lie est assez étrange
et énigmatique
là je vous renvoie à l'excellent billet
de blog de david o après sur sur 70 où
il parle un peu plus de tout ça pour en
finir avec la conservation de l'énergie
donc là on a vu que si on crée de
l'espace qu'on peut créer un certain
sens de l'énergie que de l'énergie noire
l'expansion de l'univers peut aussi
faire perdre de l'énergie et c'est le
cas notamment quand on regarde le fond
diffus cosmologique
à la base c'est une lumière extrêmement
énergétique extrêmement brillante
aujourd'hui c'est une lumière
extrêmement infrarouge qui a très très
peu d'énergie et ce décalage vers le
rouge cosmologique correspond à une
vraie perte de l'énergie ou d'un point
de vue global dans l'espace temps il ya
une superbe vidéo de fix girl qui
explique tout ça est en gros à la
conclusion de tout ça c'est qu'il a une
concertation locale de l'énergie qui est
à relier notamment au théorème de
notaire
mais il n'y a pas de conservation
globale de l'énergie parce que au niveau
cosmologique c'est vraiment très très
très grande échelle
l'univers n'est pas statique à travers
le temps elle espère que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo la prochaine fois on va
parler des paradoxes des jumeaux et du
grand-père qui correspondent à des
voyages dans le temps que permettent les
équations de la relativité générale a
dit pas j'ai ouvert aussi un conte type
ici vous pouvez me typé pour ces vidéos
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez le
laïcat le commentaire à le partager
abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes et j'espère
que je vous verrai la prochaine fois
jour je le mette rejette l'est pas
ce qui deviendrait un jour la célèbre
théorie du big bang
fred dole de ce point de vue là il fait
oeuvre à mon avis d'ouverture d'esprit
l'inscrit dans une théorie relativiste
c'est à dire que s'il dit pas juste
baiia de la matière qui se créé voilà de
temps en temps et puis ça permet de
sauver les apparences maintenant ce qui
fait c'est qu'ils ajoutent un terme dans
l'équation d'einstein qui décrit son
univers cosmologique et ce terme qui est
responsable de la création de matière